que el país viene trabajando fuertemente
desde el inicio desde el inicio de esa
cuarentena preparándose preparando la
capacidad diagnóstico aquí tenemos una
muy buena capacidad diagnóstica
preparando la capacidad hospitalaria hoy
duplicamos la cantidad de unidades de
cuidado intensivo llegamos llevamos a
más de 30 unidades de cuidados
intensivos por cada por cada millón de
habitantes tenemos adicionalmente una
formación muy importante de los
ciudadanos respecto a la pandemia creo
que hemos logrado que los ciudadanos
tengan un buen conocimiento de la
enfermedad y tenemos protocolos y guías
de manejo en todos los frentes para
poder minimizar el contagio
adicionalmente desde el mes de julio
cuando llegamos al punto máximo de casos
pedimos en un descenso progresivo muy
lento igualmente un descenso de
fallecidos por fecha de muerte no por
fecha de reporte lo que nos permite
entrar en nuestra nueva fase en una
nueva fase que no significa que el virus
se ha ido significa que el virus está
aquí pero que podemos afrontarlo de
forma responsable entre todos los
ciudadanos
el viceministro cuéntanos qué podría
pasar si con la actual reapertura los
casos de kobe 19 vuelven a aumentar en
colombia es posible regresar a la
cuarentena estamos en una fase de
aislamiento selectivo eso significa que
tenemos montar una estrategia de
búsqueda activa de pacientes pacientes
sintomáticos pacientes que posiblemente
hacen las versiones y las poblaciones de
riesgo adicionalmente tenemos un
monitoreo sobre todo el país y donde
vayamos encontrando focos o elementos de
crecimiento de casos tenemos una
prevista de herramientas previstas de
bloqueos epidemiológicos que pueden
hacerse a nivel de barrios de
localidades o pueden llegar a nivel de
ciudades pero tenemos previsto una
estrategia de aislamiento selectivo a
aislar los puntos donde tenemos
problemas no aislar todo el país y
bailar todas las ciudades
señor viceministro cuéntanos también hay
denuncias de demoras en las entregas de
los resultados lo que estaría llevando a
un retraso en el verdadero número de
contagios cada día que podemos decir de
este desfase las cifras y es si esto
permite también tomar buenas decisiones
de la política pública en el 20 de julio
finales del mes de julio última semana
primera semana del mes de agosto tuvimos
un número muy grande de casos que
llegaron a los picos se nos presentó en
ese momento congestión en la prestación
de los servicios por eso tomamos algunas
decisiones con respecto a las pruebas e
incorporamos una nueva prueba de
antígenos a la herramienta diagnóstica
en este momento el laboratorio que más
lejos tiene las pruebas las tiene a 30
días y a 30 horas perdón y estamos
reportando casi el día el 60% de la
cantidad de exámenes o sea hoy tenemos
un diagnóstico mucho más oportuno y por
eso el registro de fallecidos del día de
ayer que significa una revisión y
ponernos totalmente al día con él
con la cantidad de casos y de pacientes
que han perdido la vida
desafortunadamente